well first of all nice job on the exam
we were quite pleased with how you guys
did and so from now on in the course
professor Imperiali has been telling you
about information flow but information
flow within a cell right so information
flow from the DNA to the proteins that
are made in the cell which determines
what that cell does okay and so we're
gonna switch directions today and we're
going to start talking about how
information flows between cells so from
parent cell to its daughter cells and
we're also going to talk about how
information flows from generation to the
next
okay and this of course is the study of
genetics and what genetics is as a
discipline is it is the study of genes
and their inheritance okay and the genes
that you inherit influences what is
known as your phenotype and what
phenotype is is it simply the set of
traits that define you so you can think
of it as a set of observable traits okay
I mean and this involves your genes as
you probably know I mean just this
morning I was dropping my son off at
school and he was comparing how tall he
was compared to his classmates and as he
went in he is like thanks for the genes
dad so I expect that many of you are
gonna be familiar with much of what
we'll discuss but we're gonna lay a real
solid foundation because it's really
fundamental for understanding the rules
of inheritance
and how that works
okay so genetics is a study of genes so
what is a gene so there you can think
about genes in different ways okay and
what we've been talking about up till
now we've been talking about molecular
biology and what is known as the central
dogma and the central dogma states that
there's the source of the code is in the
DNA and there's an information flow from
a piece of DNA which is a gene and a
gene is a piece of DNA that then encodes
some sort of RNA such as a messenger RNA
and many of these RNAs can make specific
proteins that do things in your cells in
your body okay
so that's one very molecular picture of
a gene you can think of a gene as a
string of nucleotides and there might be
a reading frame and those nucleotides
that encodes a protein okay so that's a
very molecular picture of a gene right
the field of genetics started well
before we knew about DNA and its
importance and what sort of the DNA
encoded RNA which encoded proteins okay
so the concept of a gene is much older
than that
and so what you can think of a G another
way you can think of a gene is it's
essentially the functional unit of
heredity okay so it's the functional
unit of heredity
okay I'll bump this up so I want to just
briefly pause and kind of give you an
overview of why I think genetics is so
important so what you saw up here is you
saw a cell divide and I showed you this
in the last lecture you saw the
chromosomes which are here how they're
segregated two different daughters and
this is basically you're seeing the
information flow from the parent cell
into the daughter cell okay but we saw
this so I'm just gonna skip ahead so why
is this so important okay so I'm gonna
give you a fairly grandiose view of why
genetics is so important
and I'm gonna say that we can make a
good argument that genetics is
responsible for the rise of modern
civilization
okay so humans as a species began
manipulating genes and genetics even
before we had under any understanding of
what was going on so this is more of an
unconscious selection and so 10,000
years ago humans were hunter-gatherers
they'd go out and try to find nuts and
seeds and hunt animals and that's how we
got our food but around 10,000 years ago
was the first example of where humans as
a species really altered the phenotype
of a plant in this case
okay so wild wheat and wild barley the
seeds develop in a pod and the biology
of the wild wheat is such that the pod
shatters and the seeds then spread on
the ground where they can be where they
can then germinate into new plants okay
but 10,000 years ago humans decided that
it would be more ideal if we had a form
of wheat which didn't shatter which is
known as non shattering wheat which in
which the seeds remain on the plant and
that allows it to be easily harvested at
the end of the season okay
so 10,000 years ago is one of the first
examples where humans really genetically
altered the phenotype of a plant and
they selected for this non shattering
wheat which then allowed the rise of
Agriculture okay in addition to wheat we
also for about four thousand years ago
was the rise of domesticated fruit and
nuts so here are some almonds if you
would like an almond feel free to have
some you guys want some almonds nope if
you have a nut allergy don't eat them
okay great so wild almonds when you chew
them there's an enzymatic reaction that
results in cyanide forming Rachel just
stopped chewing don't worry these these
are almonds that are harvested at Trader
Joe's so you're safe and so the wild
almonds obviously were not we're not
compatible for consumption consumption
but 4,000 years ago humans again
selected for a form of the almond which
involved just a single gene which was
non bitter and known as a sweet almond
which was also not toxic okay so this
doesn't just go for foods but also for
clothing so humans have selected for
cotton with long lint and that served as
a basis for clothing and and sort of
allowing us to have fabric and I just
want to end with a little story about
the almond which is part of the
archaeological evidence for when almonds
were domesticated was when King Tut's
tomb was unearthed and they found a pile
of almonds next to the tomb because the
the Egyptian culture what they did is
they buried the dead with food to
sustain them in the afterlife okay so
that just gives you an idea as how far
back sort of the importance of genetics
goes if we think about nowadays right
now you are always seeing genetics in
the news
and you also have the opportunity
yourself to sort of do your own genetic
experiment and so now you guys are
undoubtedly aware of all these companies
that want you to send them their DNA and
they also want you to send them money
such that they can give you information
about your family tree and also
information about your health okay
and so this is now a big business but if
you but if you don't understand genetics
this is not as useful as it could be
okay so I'm just curious how many people
here have used one of these services and
had their DNA genotyped
well and do you think that that really
changed your view of who you are or was
it kind of so you're looking for genetic
disorders and you don't have to tell me
anything about that yeah so you know I
mean my I have not done this but my dad
has done it and he will go find his like
relatives and bore them with our
ancestry okay so so this is one example
of how genetics is really in play today
right and not everyone knows how this
works I've had people at Starbucks in
the morning come up to me with their
like with their like 23andme profile and
asked me to explain stuff because they
know who I am this a little awkward so
we can also use genetics for forensics
and so this is kind of a I I had a lab
manager in the lab and he told me that
like people were doing this and like
like senior homes in Florida which I
thought was kind of funny what I find
hilarious about this is the mugshot of
the dog right that dog looks so guilty
right but you can use DNA to you can use
DNA to genotype poop you genotype your
neighbor's dog you can get evidence that
they're the one that's like pooping on
your lawn
so that's not so serious example but
there are more serious examples of where
DNA genotyping is really having an
effect in our society and this is
something I mentioned in the intro
lecture just this past spring someone
was suspected as being the Golden State
killer this is a cold case the kid the
killing has happened 40 years ago but
the break came from investigators
getting DNA from the suspects relatives
to implicate this person in this crime
okay so they had DNA from the crime and
they saw that there are matches to the
DNA at the crime to certain people and
then they can reconstruct who might be
the person in the right place to commit
the crime okay so this is I think this
is interesting because it also leads to
all sorts of privacy issues right who's
gonna gain access to sort of your
genotype if you submit it to these
companies right I mean this is probably
a case right argue there's probably a
beneficial result in that you can
actually figure out if someone's
committed a crime but there are other
issues in terms of thinking about
insurance companies where we might be
interested in having our sort of
information not publicly available to
insurance companies and maybe this is
something we can discuss later on in
another lecture for today I want to move
on and go through really the
fundamentals of genetics and what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna start with the
answer okay
I'm gonna present to you guys today the
physical model for how inheritance
happens okay so today we're going to go
over the physical the physical model of
inheritance
and this physical model involves cell
division which you saw in the last
lecture and also in my opening slide it
involves cell division and the physical
segregation of the chromosomes during
cell division so also chromosome
segregation okay so these this is how
I'm gonna represent chromosomes and I
just want to kind of step you through
what all what it all means so I kind of
have these two arms that are attached to
this central circle the circle is meant
to represent the centromere so this is
the centromere and you'll remember from
the last lecture on Monday the
centromere is the piece of the
chromosome that physically is attached
to the microtubules that are gonna pull
the chromosomes to separate poles okay
so that's that's called the centromere
and usually it's denoted like a
constriction in the chromosome or a
little circle okay these other parts of
the chromosome are the arms so that you
have the arms of the chromosome now I'm
drawing what's known as a metacentric
chromosome it's not important that you
know that term but it just means that
the centromere is in the middle of the
chromosome there are other types of
chromosomes where the centromere might
be at the end okay so there are
different types of chromosomes all right
now for all of us we have cells that
have different numbers of chromosomes
okay some of our cells are what is known
as haploid and what I mean by haploid is
there is a single set of chromosomes
now the cells that we have that are
haploid are our gametes so there are
eggs and our sperm cells okay so these
include gametes okay but most of the
cells in your body are what is known as
diploid and diploid means there's two
complete sets of chromosomes okay and
you get one set from one parent the
other set from the other parent okay so
one set from each parent okay and I'll
draw the other set like this and what
I'll do is I'll just sort of shade in
this one this one to denote that it's
different okay so these two chromosomes
then are what is known as homologous
their homologous chromosomes Moll I
guess okay
and what I mean by them being homologous
is that basically these two chromosomes
have the same set of genes okay so they
have the same genes they're the same
genes but they have different variants
of those genes okay so different
variants of these genes and these
variants are referred to as alleles okay
so if you have the same gene but they
differ slightly in their nucleic acid
sequence then they're distinct alleles
of those genes so often the way
geneticists refer to these different
variants or alleles is we use a capital
letter in a lowercase letter okay so
this chromosome over here might have a
gene that's allele capital a and then
this homologous chromosome will have the
same gene but a different allele which
I'll denote lowercase a okay so in this
case big a and little a are different
alleles of the same gene they might
produce a slightly different protein
which would result possibly in a
different phenotype okay so everyone
understand that distinction oh I want to
make one point because this came up last
semester and was one of those cases
where I forgot the part about the head
so I we often just have two alleles when
we sort of teach genetics but I hope you
can see that because a gene is a long
sequence of DNA there's a ton of
different alleles you can have within a
given gene so one nucleotide difference
in that gene would result in a different
allele okay so we often refer to two
alleles but there can be more than two
alleles for a given gene okay
does everyone see how that manifests
itself okay great any questions up till
now
yes Carmen
in the population so Carmen asked well
do can I have like five alleles of a
gene and that's a great question and so
Thank You Carmen for asking that what
I'm what I mean is if we consider a
population as a whole right you have two
alleles of each gene unless it's a gene
that somehow like duplicated and so when
we're considering the population there
can be more than right I mean right I
see we have people with hair color is
not a monogenic traits are with brown
hair right there's more than just like
two possible sort of alleles with
possible phenotypes okay all right let's
go up this alright now I want to start
at the beginning where so most of our
cells are diploid and the origin of our
first diploid cell is from the union of
two gametes okay so I'm going to draw
two gametes here each is one end and I'm
just going to draw one set of
chromosomes for this here so we might
have a male gamete and a female gamete
and what I'm referring to when I say n
here n is basically referring to the
number of chromosomes number of
chromosomes perhaps I am
/ haploid genome so when you have 1n it
means you're haploid because you have
only one set of a haploid genome but
early in your life you're we're all the
result of a fusion between a male and
female gametes and so that creates a
diploid cell okay so now this diploid
zygote so this is referred to as the
zygote is diploid and now has a set of
homologous chromosomes okay so I'm only
drawing one set of homologous
chromosomes here so on the board I'm
gonna stick to just one so I don't have
to draw them all out in the slides I'm I
have three okay so each of these
represents a chromosome these are
different chromosomes different
chromosomes are their different color or
have a different sort of centromere
position and then these down here that
are colored are going to be the
homologous chromosomes okay you see how
I'm representing this okay so once you
have the zygote right so you guys are no
longer one cell right you guys each are
tens of trillions of cells so this
zygote had two the zygotes L had to
reproduce itself and your cells had to
divide so that you grew into an entire
multicellular organism just quickly
erase that
okay so when most of your cells divide
and most of your cells are known as
somatic cells when cells of your body or
your intestine and your skin when they
divide they genetically replicate
themselves and they're undergoing a type
of cell division known as mitosis okay
in mitosis in mitosis it's essentially a
cloning of a cell or ideally it's the
cloning of the cell so you have a
diploid cell it has to undergo DNA
replication and when a chromosome
undergoes DNA replication it will during
mitosis look like this okay and these
two different sort of arms or strands
they're known as sister chromatids okay
so that's just another term you should
know these are sister chromatids okay
and the sister chromatids if DNA
replication happened with any without
any errors should be exactly the same as
each other in terms of nucleotide
sequence okay so after DNA replication
this cell will essentially have four
times the amount the amount of DNA as a
haploid cell and it will split into two
cells and again they'll both be diploid
okay and I'll just point out if we're
thinking about our pair of chromosomes
here right
Egypt this parent cell has both homologs
and the daughter cells because they
should be genetically identical also
have both homologs
okay so that's an example with just one
chromosome I'll take you through an
example with these three chromosomes
here well six chromosomes so you have
these are homologs
these are homologs these are homologs
and during mitosis all all of these
chromosomes initially are kind of all
over the nucleus but during mitosis they
will align along the equator of the cell
and what is known as the metaphase plate
metaphase is just a fancy term for one
particular stage in the mitotic cycle
so's and then what will happen is the
spindle will attach to either one side
or the other side of these chromosomes
and it will physically segregate them
into different cells okay and what I
hope you see see here is that this has
six chromosomes this has six chromosomes
and these two daughter cells are
genetically identical to the parent cell
okay so this is known as an equation
elision because it's totally equal okay
and again the daughter cells are both
diploid okay so that's mitosis any
questions about mitosis okay moving on
we're going to talk now about another
type of cell and these are your germ
cells and these germ cells undergo an
alternative form of cell division known
as meiosis okay and your germ cells germ
cells produce your egg in sperm and so
meiosis essentially is producing gametes
such as egg and sperm cells okay
so what's the final product gonna be how
what should be the genomic content of
the final product of meiosis it should
be one end right who said that
sorry yeah exactly right what's your
name Jeremy so Jeremy is exactly right
right the germ cells in order to
reproduce sexually they should be
haploid cells right so that they can
combine with another haploid to give
rise to a diploid okay
so the ultimate result that we want is
to have cells that are one end but most
of our cells to start out with are
diploid so there are 2n okay so what's
special about meiosis is you're not just
going from 2 n to 2 n but you're
reducing the genetic content of the
cells you're going from 2 n to a 1 end
content
okay so again meiosis starts with DNA
replication but in this case the first
division which is meiosis 1 is not equal
and it actually segregates the homologs
such that you get one cell that has one
of the homologs duplicated and another
cell that has the other homologue
duplicated ok and I'll show this I'll
show it right now
so this is the same cell now it's
undergone DNA replication as you can see
each chromosome has two copies but
instead of all the chromosomes lining up
in the same position of the metaphase
plate what you see is that homologous
chromosomes pair at the metaphase plate
and what happens here is that the
homologous chromosomes are separated to
different cells and now you have two
cells that are not genetically identical
okay so because there's it's not
equational it's and there's a reduction
in the genetic material that's present
in the cells this is known as a
reduction Allah vision okay so that's
meiosis one and that's a reduction old
division and then but this is not yet
haploid and so I'll just stick another
one in here these cells then undergo
another round of division which is known
as meiosis two and during this meiosis
these sister chromatids are separated
such that you're left with one
chromosome and by drawing at least one
chromosome / / gamete okay so each of
these then is 1n
okay so again you have the chromosomes
but this time you you have them aligned
like in mitosis they align the sister
chromatids are physically separated and
now you see this cell is genetically
identical to this cell and this cell
here is genetically identical to this
cell okay so that's meiosis 2 and that's
an equation older vision much more like
mitosis okay because the product of the
division of those two cells each of
those is equal okay and the finally the
result of meiosis 2 is that you're then
left with gametes that have a haploid
content of their genome ok I want to end
lecture by doing a demonstration let's
see so this could either be amazing or
it will be a complete disaster so we're
totally going to do it
so what everyone come up
[Music]
wait here
sure
Evelynn when you can leave when you have
to go and we'll have a chromosome loss
event okay you just have to be a
multiple of four if we have extra people
they and the people can supervise go
oops sorry
alright we got here
here you go Brett Andrew sorry I hope
I'm not hitting anybody what's that yeah
that's the didn't see advantage of these
all right there you go miles let's see
there you go
sorry someone take this all right what
do we got here
got a little chromosome here sorry all
right who doesn't have a chromosome
everyone in the class has a chromosome
all right one of you wanna come in here
all right we'll see how constrained we
are in terms of space we've never been
this ambitious and had this many
chromosomes before so I'm excited to see
how this works so you each have a swim
noodle there are different colors so
different colors represent different
chromosomes and then you also have swim
noodles that have tape on them and these
represent different alleles from your
other chromosomes so these two
chromosomes would be homologs of each
other okay does that make sense okay
great
all right now the metaphase plate will
be kind of along the center of the room
so let's first reenact mitosis so why
don't you guys find your sister
chromatid and then sort of a line in the
middle of the room here sister or
brother chromatid
how are we doing do we have enough space
there it's a little packed you can see
how you know the cell you can imagine
how packed it is inside a cell okay
everyone found their sister chromatid
normally the sister chromatids they
replicate and they get held together so
there's no finding of sister chromatids
but all right great
so segregate and we'll see how you guys
did all right in the goal is that you
guys would be genetically identical
saris okay great
that looks like one short red one short
red that's good they look genetically
identical to me alright so that was
mitosis now we're gonna do meiosis okay
want you guys aligned like like what
would happen during meiosis one okay you
guys can come back think about who
you're gonna pair with
oh all right so what were you looking
for when you were pairing who were you
looking for your prohm is ohm right okay
great all right why don't you guys
segregate
alright so that was my OSIS 1 meiosis
one looks successful to me and now we
have to undergo meiosis 2 so maybe what
we could do is you guys can rotate in
the metaphase spindle can be sort of in
this orientation yeah yeah well we want
to group over there a group over there
grow a group here group here and those
will be our four gametes all right you
guys set all right go okay terrific
everyone haploid looks like everyone is
haploid which is good right so look
let's just take a minute and think about
probability here so what was the
probability that a gamete would end up
with this orange allele on the red
chromosome huh maybe is there two right
so these two gametes have that allele
these two should not right okay great we
just had a chromosome loss so that
gamete is in trouble but maybe we could
get a TA to rescue this chromosome
either one of you is fine there you go
David
all right that was great
now let's you know as you're doing this
right you kind of get a sense as to how
things could get mixed up right and you
know you think inside the cell right so
I don't I've lost track of how many
chromosomes we have one two three four
five six right how many chromosomes do
we have
we are haploid set for us is how many
chromosomes 23 exactly right so it'd be
even worse for a human cell to get this
to go right
so why don't you guys line up in the
mitosis configuration and we'll consider
some things that could go wrong
all right who here is good friends with
their with their sister or brother
chromatid there's anyone very good
friends with their sister or brother
chromatid yeah someone become good
friends and become inseparable okay
which with someone volunteer to be
inseparable okay great you guys are now
inseparable okay now segregate okay
great now what happened there
what's that yeah that sell stolen
okay so now we have to a duplication of
that chromosome what's happened over
here with this daughter cell it's
missing a chromosome right so these are
the types of mistakes that can be
associated with a cell becoming
cancerous right because let's say there
was a gene that suppresses growth on
that chromosome and it wasn't on that
homologue then you might result in
genetic sort of mutant or loss of that
gene that would result in uncontrolled
proliferation also picking up the copies
extra copies of genes that promote
growth could allow that cell to have a
proliferative advantage okay we're gonna
this is sort of short foreshadowing what
we're going to talk about later but I
just want to kind of like plant the seed
now okay why don't we go back and do my
OSIS
okay now anyone see any friends looking
across the aisle now all right great
you guys are now inseparable why don't
you guys segregate except the
inseparable ones oh but but your sister
chromatids still have to stay attached
there you go see great right so just
like last time that this is known as a
non distinct disjunction event where the
chromosomes don't separate when they
should okay great now we want you guys
do meiosis to
all right you can segregate
all right now you see these two gametes
over here are lacking an entire orange
chromosome and these two gametes here
have picked up an additional copy of an
orange chromosome okay so they're this
the two gametes are no longer haploid
for the orange chromosome and if one of
these gametes were to fused with a
haploid gamete that has an orange
chromosome then now you have a zygote
that has three copies of the orange
chromosome which is abnormal okay so if
that work froma zome 21 in humans that
would result in something that's called
trisomy 21 which is Down syndrome okay
so you see how mistakes and how Roma's
ohms segregate can result in human
disease okay well we give give
yourselves a hand good job okay you can
just throw the pool noodles on the side
and I just have one slide to show you
where we're going next
she said throat yeah can you share those
you're asking if there's crossing over
yeah there's crossing over yes and that
will that will that will get its own
entire lecture yes good question
okay so just to give you guys a preview
of what's up next so in the next lecture
we're going to talk about Mendel and
Mendel's peas and we'll talk about the
laws of inheritance okay and realize
Mendel you know this Mendel is way
before DNA or what our knowledge of the
gene was okay next we'll talk about
fruit flies and Thomas Hunt Morgan and
seminal work that led to the chromosome
model of inheritance and also resulted
in the concepts of linkage and also
genetic Maps okay we're gonna go well
just sort of anchor yourself right the
structure of DNA was published in 1953
so these seminal genetic studies up here
were done before we knew about DNA so
geneticists were studying genes and
their behavior well before we knew DNA
was what was responsible and then we'll
talk about sequencing and the sequencing
Rezo revolution will talk about cloning
and molecular biology and how one might
go from a human disease to a specific
gene that causes it and then finally
we'll start talking about entire human
genome and genome sequences okay so
that's just a preview of where we're
going so have a great weekend
[Music]
you